[Music]
let's go to tim also in minnesota what's
up tim how we doing man
hey dr john how are you good what's
going on man uh not too much man
um
so i just uh was looking for some
clarity here i know you always say
don't lie to your kids um i was
wondering where hold on
just just starting it with this makes
this my favorite call of the year so far
so i know you say don't lie to my kids
but
this is gonna be good so what is it um
so me and my wife are just wondering
where we draw that line at um as
brother just get it what'd you do
we were both
in a relationship uh
when we met and my oldest daughter was
conceived hey oh there it is we all
married
uh no no okay
so y'all were just dating other people
and then
yeah some say love
and then
all she wrote and then your daughter was
like hey oh and so are y'all married now
yes we are okay how are things
uh they're good they're good
have y'all cheated on each other since
cheers
i'm sorry have you all cheated on each
other since then
uh there has been some infidelity god
almighty quit y'all are a bunch of
cheaters why
uh that's a good question oh it wasn't
you
uh it's been both of us oh my god quit
cheating all right what's your question
that's a whole other call
oh well we just
what do we
what do we tell our daughter as far as
you know how we met and
what happened there i mean how much is
too much for her
how old is she
uh right now she's five so we got some
time no i think you tell her everything
today i think you tell her that mom and
dad are a bunch of cheaters and no don't
tell her that good gosh
all right um
okay big picture stop cheating both of
you quit
stop yeah right
quit yep quit
what have you done to say to make sure
this never happens again
uh
like what have you done
what have i done yes
in your life so that you never cheat
again
because this is your second relationship
that you've done this in a row and it's
not your first either
yeah um
not cheated anymore no no no no it
doesn't start there where what have you
done have you got all rid of all the
social media apps you're never gonna go
on lunches with a with a female
co-worker ever again
like what have you what what roadblocks
have you put in front of yourself to
keep this from happening again
um
i mean we haven't deleted all social
media but we have limited what what we
use
um i don't particularly have any female
co-workers
okay
all right so here's the thing number one
you all got to get in a room and figure
this out because you'll be having this
conversation in divorce court with your
daughter and it's going to be a mess
don't do that to her okay
yep the second thing is this
um
the honesty rule even though you asked
that question so great it's so good man
so i know you say never lie um
yes you still don't lie
but don't over share to make yourself
feel better
okay and a lot of parents have this
sense of guilt um hey we had this kid
out of you know out of wedlock or we
were both married to somebody else then
we hooked up and got pregnant now this
kid
and it feels like i've gotta atone for
all my sins with this kid i'm gonna dump
all my crap onto this child just so i
can there's no
don't do that to a kid that's too much
right that's this toxic over-sharing
world we live in now
so i think you're honest for a long long
time
and you tell them what they what she
wants to know when she asks questions so
for instance what's your origin story
how'd you meet she doesn't have to know
you are dating other people
she just
knows how you met how'd y'all meet
uh through an online app oh my gosh
that's so great what was it what was the
app
uh
to be honest with you i don't remember
it's been years now
oh your other girlfriend i bet she's so
incredible
she loves this
um
so yeah you met on the internet just
like millions and millions of other
couples have and uh we went to
uh i don't know we went somewhere and
then we
had you i think that's where you have
that conversation
as your kid get gets older you can be
more honest but dude i really recommend
answering questions only that your kid
asks there may come a day when your kid
is 18 or 22 or
30 and y'all are out and you want to
have a a conversation conversation
that's cool but that's less that's more
about them getting to know
their origin story and less about dad
trying to make himself feel better
or mom trying to make herself feel
better
probably what's going to happen is she's
going to be in high school and
somebody's going to cheat on her and
she's going to be devastated by it and
she's going to say you don't know what
this is like you don't know me you don't
know what's happening and you're going
to say i got a story for you
and that's when you can connect
empathetically with your dog you say
like hey our stories are more similar
than you think but don't ever ever ever
lie
okay my friend rachel says share don't
scare right the thing you don't want to
communicate to your kid is yeah this
could happen any time again
anytime and by the way we're still
cheating
even though even since you've been born
we're still cheating we're just a couple
of cheaters like that's what's gonna
freak your kid out and give her an uh
she's going to not have a stable
foundation to build her her esteem off
of her support networks her
relationships off of if she thinks at
any moment one of these two are going to
go again and create another family
somewhere else that's what you want to
avoid right
okay so have you had that conversation
like how does this go with you and your
wife
uh
i'm i'm not sure what you're asking
when you all discuss like what do we
think we should do what i'm interested
in y'all's answers
um we we've always just said we met we
we met online that's what we would say
when time comes that's 100 accurate 100
fair
okay you don't have to tell them that
mom and dad weren't great people
and tim quit cheating
understood you promise
promise in front of america
in front of all 17 listeners oh there's
19 now sucker we picked up two over the
holidays it was awesome
so big weekend
we had a big weekend that's right um
why is she cheating on you
uh
i
i don't know
i was i think i was
uh working more
than uh
than she uh liked with having a new baby
at home and maybe it was just another
source of attention
did you ever go to marriage counseling
uh we haven't okay
so
i want you all to make that a a1
priority because i don't think it is i
think you all are white-knuckling your
way through it right now
and your need for attention or your
inability to give each other care or to
even say here's what i need from you and
i can provide that or i can't provide
you all need to go learn some language
and some tools
okay your daughter's worth that y'all
two are worth that you my brother are
worth that
and
the answer you gave isn't the reason she
would cheat
and but i
i want you all to get into a room and
say all right we are actually in a good
place right now we're not on life
support we're not trying to deal with
somebody else cheated somebody else did
something things are good
we want to cheat proof this marriage we
want to create an environment where that
never ever ever happens again and let's
start from square one and if y'all do
that you can build something
extraordinary and strong that will last
forever
yes if you don't you're going to be
calling me back in a few months or a few
years and we're going to be having a
whole different conversation and i don't
want that for you and i don't want that
for that sweet little girl
yes is that cool
yeah absolutely awesome commit to that
brother you're worth that your wife's
worth that and that man that beautiful
beautiful little girl's worth that dude
don't cheat and don't lie to your kid